un droit de réponse rokhaya diallo ayant
été nommément mises en cause par le
philosophe michel onfray dans l'émission
en direct de mercredi dernier elle nous
a demandé un droit de réponse que nous
lui avons bien entendu accordé en kayak
diallo vous dites que michel onfray dit
que vous avez dit ce que vous avez dit
vous ne l'avez jamais dit droit de
réponse alors oui j'ai été très étonné
d'entendre mon surgir au milieu
d'accusations très très violente et très
sexiste
quant au fait que certaines personnes
trouverait des excuses à certains
violeurs parce qu' il serait considéré
comme raciste et je cite les termes de
michel onfray et que c'est ces viols
seraient en fait les une espèce de
revanche cost postcoloniale et que je
ferai partie des personnes qui
défendrait cette thèse absolument
sexistes et un raciste puisque
effectivement elle prêterait une un
régime d'exception au viol qui seraient
commis par des personnes selon leur
origine j'étais extrêmement choquées de
voir mon nom en fait mobiliser à ce
moment là pour moi il s'agit pas
simplement d'une joute sur un plâtre
télévision mais véritablement d'une mise
en cause de mon honneur qui matin et qui
atteint mon entourage sachant que je
suis engagé dans le combat féministe
depuis quand même deux décennies et que
j'aie jamais prêt donner d'excusés en
fait pour aucune actes aucun acte
violent
tiens d'ailleurs à lire un extrait d'un
texte que j'avais publié après des viols
dont il a été fait mention
j'avais publié en février 2016 dans
libération et j'avais expliqué qu'en
fait j'étais en contact avec des
féministes allemande et j'avais expliqué
car hashtag qui s'appelait alors on aime
ce losc qui signifie un mâle main pas d'
excuses avaient été créés et ça
signifiait d'une certaine manière pas
d'exception donc là je cite le texte que
j'avais écrit parce que nous nous
élevons de manière systématique et
absolue contre toutes les violences
quelles que soient leurs auteurs
pas de circonstances atténuantes et
excuses ni de circonvolutions ni de oui
mais toutes les formes de sexisme sont
intolérables et doivent être punis je
regrette en fait que mon nom a été
avancé avec une telle imprudence dans un
souci en fait de démonstration quant au
fait que certaines femmes seraient des
féministes à géométrie variable et je
regrette également devoir
particulièrement aujourd'hui puisque
nous sommes le 8 mars que finalement
de nombreuses personnes ne s'exprime
jamais contre le sexisme qui court en
fait de manière extrêmement endémique
dans notre société
sauf quand il s'agit d'accuser des
femmes particulièrement des femmes non
blanches d'être à l'origine d'une forme
de féminisme de féminisme géométrie
variable pour répéter ce que j'ai dit à
l'instant alors il faut savoir juste
pour information que michel onfray m'a
fait contacté et m'a indiqué qu'il
présenterait des excuses publiques
je prends acte de cette prise de contact
et de cet engagement
ça n'enlève rien aux dommages qui ont
été causés mais je pense que c'est
effectivement la moindre des choses que
de réparer une faute quand elle porte
des accusations aussi graves
merci rokhaya diallo dont acte puisque
et je vous fais toutes mes excuses de ne
pas avoir rectifié
mais on était en direct et et je ne
savais pas exactement ce que vous aviez
pu dire ou laisser entendre
à cette époque là voilà c'est fait merci